LAURENCE MORONEY:
So anybody who's
been to any developer event
in the last couple of years,
usually Android or Android
Studios in the keynote,
Stephanie, you're the
person that we get to see.
You get to make all
the cool announcements.
And this year at I/O was a
particularly special one.
Could you tell us about it?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: It
was an incredible year.
Android had a whole ton
of developer announcements
that we were super
excited about.
And I think probably
everybody knows
Kotlin was at the
top of our list
and at the top of a
lot of people's lists.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
You did a great job
keeping that a secret.
It was such a big surprise
and a great reveal.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
That was really tough.
It was something the
community had been asking us
for again and again.
And in fact, one of the funniest
moments behind the scenes
was about three weeks,
I think, before I/O, we
had O Labs, which is
one of the events where
we bring a ton of apps--
we bring a ton of apps in just
to help them get ready for O.
So there are probably like
250 apps there, maybe 300,
or representatives from
the various top apps.
And somebody in the
audience asked Mike Claron,
who's the director of
the framework, Mike,
what do you think about Kotlin?
And when are you guys
going to adopt Kotlin?
And of course, we had
made the decision.
And we were just
spooling up for I/O.
Mike had actually
helped me co-write
the keynote speech, which
we were rehearsing by then.
And Mike, you could see his
face just kind of light up.
And he turns to the person,
and he says, you know,
there's a lot going
on with Kotlin.
And I'm sure you're
seeing a lot.
We're seeing everything
you're seeing.
And we just want
you to know that.
And I thought as soon
as he said that--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's a great answer.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: I know.
I thought he'd actually
blown the whole surprise.
So I immediately went
and checked reddit
the next afternoon
because I thought,
someone's going to be able
to read between the lines.
But nobody did, and
it was a surprise.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's good.
And social media lit up
after it was announced.
It was overwhelming.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Yeah.
Well, I think it was just
what everyone wanted.
And it was the right decision.
And everyone knew it
was the right decision.
So I think it was really
a credit to the community
that they were so clear with
us about like, look, this
is the right thing to adopt.
In fact, the way we've talked
about it is entirely accurate.
I think Kotlin's this incredible
fit for the Android platform
because it's so
rare that you get
a language that's so mature.
And it's a
five-year-old language.
It's highly mature.
It's gone through a 1.0 stage.
And yet you can adopt it into
apps completely integrated.
So you can have an app that
has Java code and Kotlin
code completely integrated.
So at the point of
announce, most languages
are still in a developmental
stage or an early stage.
And Kotlin is really in a very
mature state on a platform that
is very widely scaled.
So it was super unusual.
And to have that
plus the IDE support
because the same people
designing the language
built the IDE was just amazing.
And so I think we were
really excited about it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It was just
perfect serendipity as well,
right?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
It was the right time,
the right stuff, and all that.
Now you work on Android
Studio primarily.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: I do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You talk
a lot about Android Studio.
So how are things going
with Android Studio?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: They're
going really well, yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
just released version 3?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Yes.
Version 3 is
currently in Canary.
The next I'd trust after
that would be beta.
And version 3 is the
one that supports
the current release of Android.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
Now for a developer like
me, an Android developer,
I started cutting my
Android teeth with Eclipse.
It was interesting.
It had its moments.
But it was still great
to have that power
to be able to develop and
deploy onto something.
So Android Studio was
the next logical step.
And I came from a world with
Visual Studio beforehand,
so Android Studio felt
much more familiar.
And it was exciting.
But it's come a long way
in the couple years, right?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: It has.
And I think that really reflects
the investment in the IDE.
One of the things that
happened for us was we
realized several years ago that
Android had scaled massively.
And as Android scaled,
the developer community
was also scaling massively.
People think about a
US-based community,
people who are in the US.
But really if you
think about it,
the European
community is enormous.
The Chinese developer
community on Android is huge.
The Indian community
is exploding.
Brazil, there's so
many different places.
And I think what had happened is
we really outstripped the IDE.
And we needed to
invest very deeply
to give developers
what they needed.
And developers were very
articulate about the features
they needed, which was awesome.
And so what you're
seeing really is
a reflection of increasing
investment in Android Studio.
And that investment is
continuing to increase.
And so there are a
number of features
that have come out in
the past several years
that I think are
super exciting, and I
think you should expect
to see that continue.
So yeah, it's been
a really fun time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So I have a
couple of favorite features.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Tell me.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So I absolutely love
the new assistants, particularly
the Firebase assistant.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
That is so cool.
The original design
for that feature
was one where you
came in, and there
was just all this stuff you
had to connect here, and do
this, and do that.
And we looked at it.
And we thought, even
we can't figure out
how to get through that.
Why don't we make it a
step-by-step process?
And I think the result
is so useful because it's
relatively straightforward.
In fact, we're using that
same assistant concept now
with other types of guided
journeys through the IDE.
And I think that's going to
be a really good baseline.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
I can't wait to see
some of the others.
I've been writing
a book on Firebase.
And it used to be-- you made
me rewrite all my chapters,
by the way.
It used to be that.
It was like, go to the console.
Turn this on.
Turn that on.
Get the Google
services JSON file.
Download it.
Find the right
folder in your app.
Put it in.
Now it's the Firebase assistant.
Click a button.
Even the dependencies are added
to the build up [INAUDIBLE]..
It's beautiful.
I'm looking forward
to seeing more.
And then my other
favorite is the Emulator.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Yes.
The Emulator is amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It used to
be that the scenarios you'd
get in the Emulator
were kind of limited.
You needed a real
device to do it.
But now there's
just so much stuff
happening in the Emulator.
You've even added the
Google Play Store,
so things like
Google Play Services
will update automagically as
I'm building my apps for it.
So thank you.
Great work.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
I'm so glad you like it.
Yeah, I feel like the
Emulator itself particularly
has come so far in
terms of performance
because it's so snappy
and responsive now.
It's actually much faster for
me to deploy under the Emulator
than a device.
And I typically do
development on both.
But also the feature
set is really nice,
like being able to turn
network on and off.
And mocking maps is one of my
favorite and things like that.
So I think there's
still a lot more
we could do with the Emulator.
I personally think
it'd be great to have
it boot incredibly fast.
I think it would be wonderful
to see the Emulator have
more features.
Especially things like
different types of network
connectivity are things that
developers in emerging markets
talk about, even developers
in the US and Europe
targeting those markets.
So there's so much
more that we can do.
But I think it
really is one where
it's now a mainline
part of the workflow.
We don't release adoption
stats, but it's just
going through the roof.
People are using it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Stephanie's smiling now,
but I gave her a hard
time about the Emulator
and Google Play Services for
a long time, but not anymore.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Yes.
That is true.
That was-- yeah,
that was a good--
you were right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Do you have
any favorite features yourself?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: I do.
You mentioned one of them.
The Emulator is definitely
one of my favorites.
I personally really
like ConstraintLayout.
When the initial version of
ConstraintLayout came out,
I was playing with
different layouts.
And I find it super useful,
especially in the new world
where you're seeing a lot
of dynamic form factors.
It's really useful to be able
to define things in relation
to each other as
opposed to having those
static definitions.
So that's a huge
favorite for me.
There are little things
that are my favorite.
So I have big things like
that, ConstraintLayout,
which obviously was
a huge investment.
The build time improvements--
especially if you've tried 3.0
and you have a huge project,
you will find the build
and sync improvements
are amazing.
And I, probably like
you and other folks
who are building big projects,
I have some pretty big,
complex apps.
And the incremental build
times are just so much better.
I feel like that will
probably be something
we'll be working
on for a long time
because developers
always tell us
we just can't make it too fast.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It
can never be too fast.
Actually a funny story
with that is that for me,
for a lot of the small test
apps that I've been building,
so many times I thought the app
hasn't deployed to the Emulator
yet.
And it's like so I have a
previous version running.
And then I compile and get
it to run the next version.
And then I go away
and do something
for a couple of minutes.
And then I come
back, and I think
it's my old version
that's still there.
But the new one is on there.
And I'm like, come on.
Hurry up.
And I don't realize
the new one is there.
It's having been used to it
being a little bit slower.
And it's like now that it's
getting faster and faster,
I have to change the way I do
things, which is kind of cool.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Yeah.
I think we want it
to just be instant.
The other one I'd
mentioned too--
and this is kind of one of
the smaller but cool ones.
I think Lint is really
useful because it's
like your extra
brain, all of it.
It's like the Rumsfeld quadrant.
Things you don't know you don't
know it tells you to look for.
So I find that really useful.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Exactly.
Because you can end up
writing some pretty ugly code
without realizing it.
And other people
have to maintain it.
So the Linting tool
is really neat.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Yes.
I definitely make mistakes
I didn't know I made.
So they're great.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if
I'm a developer getting
started with Android Studio,
or with Android in general,
or mobile development
in general,
what would you tell me?
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: I
would tell you two things.
I would tell you
download Android Studio.
And I would recommend
taking a look at Kotlin.
Again, the inside
story of how we adopted
Kotlin is essentially that one
person after another person
tried it and convinced the
next person down the line
that they had to try it,
and they had to try it.
It's one of those
languages that you just
fall in love with because
the more you use it,
the more delightful
you realize it is.
So I think I would
probably recommend
doing those two things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Absolutely.
And with Kotlin, for example,
just a funny story for me
was that a week before
I/O, I was doing some talks
at a conference in the UK.
And they were doing a
round of lightning talks.
And I did a talk on Google Maps.
And the idea was they wanted
to get an applause-o-meter.
And the Google Maps
applause-o-meter
was really good.
And I was like, yay, I'm
going to win this thing.
And then a guy came
on after me and spoke
about this thing called Kotlin
that I had never heard of.
And the crowd went wild.
And I'm like, OK, I have
to learn about Kotlin.
And then the next week, I'm
sitting in the audience at I/O,
and you go do the
whole thing K thing.
We've got Kotlin
in Android Studio.
So I was like, score.
I was excited.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
So awesome.
I'll never forget because the
same thing happened to me.
So I was in London,
and someone told me
you've got to try this language.
And it was kind of working its
way through the engineering
team.
And I got on the plane.
I had two books on Kotlin,
and my laptop, and 10 hours.
And I got on the plane, and
I thought, wow, you know,
I'm not sure we can really
put another programming
language on Android.
And by the time I landed,
I was thinking to myself,
OK, we have to figure out
how we're going to do this.
This is just so awesome.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I think
one of the neat things--
and it was something-- we did an
episode with Jeffrey van Gogh.
What he shared
with us is the fact
that how it interrupts
with existing Java code.
It's not like if you've got
existing Java libraries,
you have to throw them away
and rewrite them in Kotlin.
It's like you can start
consuming and vice versa.
And then also the
tooling, you've
got your [INAUDIBLE]
new Kotlin experience.
So you don't feel that you
have to start from ground zero
to be able to build in Kotlin
because you can actually
reuse your existing stuff.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON: Yeah.
I think that's the
one thing, too,
that was also very
eye-opening for me
when I used the language,
because you think,
oh, a new language.
I'm going to have to learn all
this new stuff and start over.
And what you really want
to know is, wouldn't it
be cool if I could be able
to write all of my code
and write it many times faster--
but do it in a
way where learning
the new syntax, learning
the new language,
is going to be
really easy for me
and where I can just take
little pieces of it at a time?
And in fact, that's
exactly what Kotlin is.
Because I think for
most people, they'd
say when they learned
Kotlin for anyone who
knows the Java program language
already, it's really not
difficult. There's so many
concepts and paradigms that
are really familiar.
So it's not like you're
moving in some huge direction.
Like you started with Java, and
now you're going to learn C++--
which I remember when I
learned that, and I thought,
OK, this is hard.
So it's quite seamless.
And that, plus the
fact that you can
take an app that's already
completely working in Java
and then just try a little
piece of it in Kotlin,
means it's so easy to just
dip your toe in and get
really comfortable.
And the IDE makes it
so seamless because you
can literally just drop a class
and it'll convert for you.
The [INAUDIBLE] team is amazing.
They're really good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So for somebody to get
started in Android Studio,
we'll put the link
in the comments.
We'll put the link in the
description of the video here,
so people can go download it.
So thank you so much, Stephanie.
It's been a real blast having
so much fun geeking out
over Android Studio with you.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
It's really cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of Coffee with a Googler.
If you have any questions for me
or any questions for Stephanie,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
Thanks again.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cheers.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Thank you so much.